it is time to turn your great idea into
a reality with
squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
do you want to showcase all that work
you've been doing do you want to sell
all those products you've been making
they have beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can easily make a beautiful
website by yourself
but if you do get stuck they have 24 7
award-winning customer support that is
there to help you out
so head to squarespace.com grace for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code grace to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
get ready
for a very fun episode we have tara
strong on this week's episode and
you might not know this but she is the
voice of your childhood she is an
amazing
amazing voice over actor i'm talking
timmy turner fairly oddparents
raven teen titans bubbles powerpuff
girls you know this woman's voice she is
everywhere and she's in my little pony
pony life which is
back on discovery family uh
she's playing twilight sparkle and you
are just gonna love it we talk about
everything
the tips and tricks for getting into the
voice over world and sustaining your
voice we talk about
what it's like having two young teenage
boys that she's raising
uh what her experience moving from
canada to los angeles was like
and how wonderful the brony community
is if you didn't already know get ready
to learn how sweet and loving they are
this is a wonderful episode i enjoyed
talking to tara so much so i hope you
enjoy listening
enjoy not too deep but tara strong
tara thank you for being here i'm so
excited to talk to you
oh thanks for having me of course the
first question
i absolutely have to ask you is um
to please enlighten us about the the
puppy in your life with the pink ears
and the pink tail
do you love her i love her who is she
how did she get such an iconic look
going for herself
she really gets a lot of attention so
that's latka and
my and my cleaning lady eight years ago
her dog she let her dog go to her
friend's house for a babysitting weekend
came back pregnant there were five girls
so i took one and all my friends took
the other so we have little parties with
them
uh with the five sisters and i don't
know what she is she's
half poodle have something and then we
got bernie's mountain dog who is
the most beautiful dog you've ever seen
so i figured lakka had to compete in the
pretty department so
we went pink and it's really funny we go
to the groomer and in la um
we're at pet euphoria and they're
amazing and
every time she gets it redone she like
struts in the house like she knows
she knows and she loves she loves it so
much so
i love it as someone that is so overdue
to get my roots done
it's very inspiring to see a woman i
just did mine yesterday and i would not
were i not filming a tv show right now
like
i i went all covered not getting my
roots done and i kind of liked it it was
like brown to here
and then it looked like a balayage but i
i didn't i have a human that did not do
hair or nails until i
had to for a show yeah no that's my
grooming
any sense of like hygiene or grooming i
have is solely based on the fact that it
i i have to represent myself on some
sort of set or some sort of project
right otherwise why bother i don't and
anything other than sweatpants and
jammies uh
i mean you know this uh routine of
wardrobe i'm sure
because the work in which you are most
known for basically the voice of our
generation
growing up uh you must get to
uh express yourself in a comfort sense
in your fashion in that world yeah
usually it really doesn't matter what
you look like or what you're wearing but
i will say like the day you come from a
workout and look like crap they're like
oh we forgot to tell you access
hollywood's shooting behind the scenes
today
perfect great thanks for that well
they're getting some real
access to me right now i mean for the
most part
we get to go in pretty comfy and
certainly during covid um any of the
voiceover stuff i've had i'm
in this home studio where i am right now
and it's been such a blessing to have
the voiceover
world because it's the only leg of the
business that didn't miss a beat
although
news outlets and podcasts too anything
where you didn't have to be
it's amazing how quickly that part of
the industry evolved
you know we're all engineers we're all
lighting people we're all making people
we're all
adapting in the best way possible i know
and we're all
excusing and forgiving each other for
everything that we're trying to handle
well let me talk to you about the
beginning of this
how did you start out in the world
of voiceover was this something that
happened accidentally was this something
that you were interested in
how did it begin it was kind of
accidental like i knew when i was four
or five years old that i wanted to be a
singer dancer actress
i liked animation i did funny voices and
accents i didn't know it was a career
i grew up in toronto and my agent
um who i who i got when i was 13 who was
still my same agent today
wow yeah sent me out for the voice of
hello kitty
and that was my first animated show that
same year i booked an on-camera show
with mr t and a theater production
so the next thing uh that's a mad lib
sentence that you just
filled in right there so true show with
mr t
um no but really the rest is history and
toronto
and toronto and vancouver you know
canada such a great place to
get a resume for um experience in the
entertainment industry because they
really got it down and
toronto backs as many um you know cities
in the united states so there's always
stuff going on here and
i had a very consistent career before i
moved to los angeles
and um in la booking
my uh booking uh powerpuff girls batgirl
um at the same time sort of put me on
the map there but i had already had
over 20 animated series to my name
before i moved there so wow and so much
of animation
is experience you know when you're in
the studio a lot
um the really legendary voice actors
have had many years under their belt and
so much of that gives you confidence and
inspires every day every day i'm
inspired by something that my cohorts
can do
that's so cool because i imagine that
the voice over world
like the entertainment industry can get
kind of small at times like you must
kind of all know or hear of each other
information yeah animation in particular
is a very very small world i know
i mean if if someone says oh i have a
friend in animation give me their name
we all know everybody in the business
and with that said it's hard to break in
so i
i understand that new talent can be
discouraged but there's always room for
upcoming new
super talented people i always tell
people not to enter that arena until
you're really ready
um because it is such a hard world to
break into yeah it's
i mean it's one of those worlds that i
think from the outside can get really
overlooked at how
actually difficult and complex
it is especially when you're doing so
many different voices and you're giving
a completely different character and
tone and quality behind every single
voice
what were the things or like the major
things that kind of surprised you when
you first got into it about
like do you do the celine dion keep your
voice quiet for 24 hours before you do a
performance
were there things that like little tips
or tricks here and there that you picked
up when you first got into it
not really like um well that was kind of
nice to hear
yeah no when i first started you know
i'm 13 so i'm excited to get a gig
right um i've never been a human that
smoked or
enjoys screaming at large venues so
you have to take care of your voice it's
the muscle and i
take sing lessons still today um i
always recommend
for people to take acting lessons
singing lessons improv study so that
you're really ready
um when you get your opportunity and um
in terms of preparation
i would say like if i have to sing on a
show i'll warm up with a vocal exercise
that i've
taped from a singing lesson um if we get
the scripts in advance
it's good to read them specifically to
know the stage directions because if the
line is whoa
it's going to be different if you're
falling off a cliff or you're seeing a
cute guy right
so you have to know what's going on
because in voiceover as opposed to on
camera there is no evidence of what
you're acting to in front of you
so you have to bring that out with your
voice um so
the prep is also if you're replacing a
voice if you're doing a celebrity
impression if there's an accent you
don't know
but on the day-to-day i don't do much in
terms
of um you know little
tricks or things i do like to have a
bunch of different kinds of drinks with
me like
i like to have like a latte a water and
a soda
like yeah it's like a regular brunch
basically
a little bit of everything yeah uh is
there
so you started basically like you're 13
and then you're working in the world
uh more and more and you moved to los
angeles
did you find yourself being typecast
in the voice world or yeah i think that
happens a lot i think
more in our in los angeles than anywhere
else
i think there is a strange
thing that happens in la where they say
oh that's the soap actor that's the
commercial actor that's the voice actor
yeah that's the stage actor they do it
to writers that's the comedy writer
that's the
soap writer right and the truth is if
people work a lot they work a lot
because they're talented and versatile
so
it's a mistake i think that hollywood
makes and sometimes people are surprised
that
a voiceover person is doing well and on
camera or
that some a-list celebrity can do good
voice-over
it's really a talent that you either
have or you don't it's like asking a tap
dancer if they do ballet and not
everybody does
it's a different skill set so you you
may very well be
great at some and not the others you can
be a singer and not a dancer
so it's it's not right to pigeonhole you
at the same time of course i'm so
grateful
that that side of the industry embraced
me because
you know friends of mine that only do on
camera go through pretty hard
times especially once reality tv took
off
there was less and less jobs for
on-camera talent unless you were an
a-list celebrity you have a-list
celebrities doing
tv that never that's where they would
never do tv so if i didn't have
animation voiceover i would be much
worse off
you know financially and also it's super
fun
like yes you get to play
in the most authentic way for a living
that must be
such a treat such a joy it is
so okay what was the first major major
gig that you got that was like holy [ __ ]
this is a pretty big deal uh i'm gonna
really have to like
step up to this uh well
i knew hello kitty from the start was a
big deal to play a title role in a
series
at 13. you know i was off to the races
with a good start
yeah and then you know beetlejuice care
bears very well known things that they
taped in toronto
then my first couple years in la i was
pretty broke
trying to get established there like
eviction notice broke
and then my very first job was given to
me by a woman named marcia goodman
and i was literally debating if i should
come back to toronto i was
i just you know desperate for money
didn't know what was going to do and
then she called me at home and said hey
do you want to be my heather we're doing
this show called gadget boy and heather
so she saved me twice really and that
afforded me enough time to stay there
then i'd say
booking batgirl powerpuff girls
and there was a series called 101
dalmatians wherein there was a hundred
guaranteed episodes which never happens
wow and all of those three were booked
at the same time and i think that made
that side of hollywood go
who's this girl um and batgirl of course
sitting alongside mark hamill kevin
conroy
like i would pinch myself every single
day and i knew then that was something
pretty big and special and still is that
show really holds up
yeah and then after that like all the
stuff i booked was
such incredible iconic roles that really
shaped like you say many childhoods and
i'm so grateful for those opportunities
like not many people can say they played
batgirl and harley
and raven and bubbles and timmy and
rugrats and all these like
iconic characters that really help to
mold um
people's lives and it's touching and
actually that's one part of the business
i really need is going to comic cons and
and shaking hands and hugging the fans
that are grateful for those moments
yeah that i'm curious about those
interactions the con
experiences especially for a voice over
person because
i'm sure obviously fans and super fans
know who you are
because they're huge fans but for the
people that
don't maybe know what you look like
physically have you had people recognize
you by your voice
before i mostly get recognized for my
face because these are fans that
google and look up their favorite voice
actors and since my speaking voice isn't
so unusual
um i don't really get um recognized
just for voice like some but some
sometimes people go oh you have a funny
voice or i hear something in your voice
but typically it's because they've
already looked online and
comic cons in particular are a place
where everybody knows the voice actors
the voice actors are lined up around the
block
and sometimes the on-camera celebrity is
like who
is that person why are they lined up and
you know it's a very um rewarding
experience
and i suspect that my predecessors
didn't know how beloved they were
because they didn't have
internet right um but meeting people at
cons that are
crying or were going through devastating
times and you know my little pony got
them through something or raven got them
through their parents divorce or
you know feeling suicidal like all kinds
of crazy stuff that comes up that
that having a character to identify with
helped people through struggles
and going to cons and meeting these
people it's so rewarding
yeah i i i mean maybe i wrote a book one
day about all that
please people i think are hungry to read
something like that especially
because you you can think of the
animated world cartoon world as sort of
like this frivolous thing but it has
true impact for people and it has like
profound relatable qualities for people
especially because these these major
shows that you've been on these run
you know five ten fifteen years long so
you raise you basically
help raise these children into adulthood
the thing i mostly get at cons is thank
you for my childhood all the time
which is just a very you know casual
message to send to someone else
the so when you get things like bubbles
and you get things like timmy
do you these things that are these
long-standing iconic characters
when you initially get like the um
description of the show or the character
do you try to find like a personal
connection to the character does that
kind of blossom
over time as you're as you're developing
the character for yourself well i think
it's true that
the first season of any show compared to
the second third fourth
are changing growing evolving when you
first have an audition for an animated
character it'll give you a drawing of
the character a character description
sometimes a show
bible and something called sides which
is a portion of the script for you to
audition with
and then you as the actor have to try to
think what production would want that to
sound like
and of course throw your own spin on it
be creative um be unafraid to be
creative um and then after the initial
audition
there are hopefully callbacks at the
callback stage
that's when it becomes a more
collaborative process where they can
direct you and
often change their mind and say well now
we want them to be a little older
younger chubby or braces
from england now they want her to be a
boy and you kind of have to be ready to
be their putty without
being you know nervous you have to be
ready to jump in which is why i always
tell people to take improv classes
because character development is so
important
um and then with that said it evolves it
changes as characters grow as
relationships
and characters grow at the same time
many animated characters
remain the same age throughout years and
years so
um it's kind of um it's an interesting
dichotomy where you
you have these characters that are so
grounded in who they are but then they
have these life experiences and grow
and my little pony is certainly
something that you can attribute
her growth and her learning about what
it means to be a leader
what it means to um have all these
friends that encourage each other that
have all their roles in their little
society and how they help each other and
how they're there for each other and
empathy and um inclusion like
over the years twilight has become you
know a teacher a force
um so for sure the writing
um lets you know where the story is
going and how your character grows and
changes
that's i okay i want to get into the the
my little pony pony life we're going to
take a quick break
um because i have a lot of questions
about bronies obviously um
that have impacted that world so we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
it's time to turn that dream of yours
into reality and guess who's there to
help you out it's squarespace they make
it easier than ever to launch your
passion project do you want to start a
new business do you want to showcase
your work
publish content maybe sell some products
or more
well squarespace is the tool for you
they have beautiful templates
created by world class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks so you can easily make
a beautiful website
all by yourself plus they have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online
and analytics that help you grow your
site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box so there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever
buying domains is super simple and you
can get all the help you need
with their 24 7 award-winning customer
support
squarespace empowers millions of people
from designers to lawyers
artists to gamers even restaurants and
gyms
remember those things they help them
turn great ideas
into something real so head to
squarespace.com grace for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain once again that's squarespace.com
grace offer code grace
okay so let's talk about my little pony
pony life
uh this premieres the show uh well this
episode will have gone up after the show
premiered on november 7th
on discovery family can you tell us a
little bit about this for people that
might not know
anything about it well i know a lot of
fans are pretty disappointed when
friendship is magic ended i was too um
so we're super excited to revisit these
characters it is all the original voice
actors from friendship is magic
it's all the original characters that
people know and love except that they've
been completely redesigned and somehow
are even cuter than before
oh that's what the world needs right now
though i know
some pony magic and french magic and
empathy um
yeah it's beautiful and it's really
colorful really fun it's faster paced
there are only 11 minute episodes
the content is a little bit sillier and
lighter kind of how titans went to go
and um it's still a tremendous amount of
fun and it still has the essence and the
heart of the original show so i think
fans of friendship as magic will still
get a kick out of this one oh that's so
exciting
and there's something i think in the the
animated world that it just has this
beautiful sense of nostalgia
that people really want and and need
at times and there's a big safety in
that i think for people
so this couldn't be coming at a better
time for everyone
agreed let's talk about the brony
community
now this is something that hit the
internet like back in the 2010s
and i i don't know that i understand it
fully i'm curious
what your take on this community is
well i also first learned about them
online
yeah and i immediately felt a connection
to them because
i'm someone that spent much of my
childhood and also
professional career fighting against
bullying and the idea that people would
be ridiculed for liking
a show because it's four girls was so
absurd and
actually this version of my little pony
was
dreamt up by lauren faust who worked on
the powerpuff girls which is another
show that transcended gender and age
and um she wanted to create characters
and story lines with more depth and um
more sort of beauty to look at other
than just selling toys
and the story lines and the characters
spoke to people
all over the world all ages all genders
didn't matter who you loved the color of
your skin where you lived who you
worshipped
and the thing that i loved about that
was the inclusion and
the idea that it didn't matter how old
you were or where you from where you
were from but they came together to love
a show and they're there for each other
like no other fandom i've ever seen and
they come together they give the most to
charity
they are the sweetest um fandom it's a
diverse fandom it's all ages
um i meet them at cons and there's
you know these extraordinary army
bronies that paint pinkie pie in their
tanks to get them through hard
times and sing pony songs and have
tattoos of the ponies on them and
they don't care that people are looking
at them and judging them and they're
very helpful to
younger generation who do feel bullied
and do feel scared and they let them
know like it gets better
yeah and the fact that there'd be you
know bullying surrounding liking a show
that
encourages friendship um empathy
understanding social awareness is so
absurd anyway so the bronies are my
people and i
i love them dearly and i would defend
them to the death so oh
that's so sweet it warms my heart
because
that is the truth that there is in
animation there is such an ability
to um sort of interweave
such profound and beautiful messages uh
that
not other like live-action shows can
really do the way the animation can do
that make it timeless that like you said
fully like encourages inclusion
and really creates a beautiful warm and
welcoming community
uh it's very cool it's one of the the
cooler things i think that the internet
has uh spawned for the world in general
absolutely now i want to know you have
two
you have children you have two sons
uh-huh now at what point did they start
realizing
that their mom was one of the most
influential people on the planet
i don't know about if they've been if
they've thought that
um but you know my kids grew up at
nickelodeon cartoon network at studios
that must have been a dream it was a
dream and it was almost challenging for
them to go to school
because when they got to school they're
like where's
kevin michael and eg daily where's all
these kick-ass voice-over people and why
is
why isn't it as colorful as nickelodeon
my son tells me that he
he remembered thinking like why don't
these other kids miss nickelodeon and
um you know they came to me with the
studios all the time
and they got to see throughout their
childhood
um how much fun it was like when the
first pony series came out and i'd come
to visit my son's school to help out at
hot lunch or volunteer all the kids
would be like
what's happening with twilight like give
us some spoilers and he was like oh
my god you know embarrassing but they
love it and you know they come with me
off into cons and like at comic-con
they get to see like at comic-con i'm
j-lo right
oh yeah strong is strong and my kid
looked up at me and he's like mom
how does that feel feel and i said well
how does that feel to you and he's like
pretty good pretty good oh that's so
sweet
yeah they're pretty supportive and they
love finding me on things that i'm not
regularly on like
family guy or rick and morty or video
games that
you know they're they weren't sure that
i was on they like to sort of find me
and different things like that
oh that must be so fun now you guys have
opened up
a school voice stars together well
i did that many many years ago
truthfully it has to be completely
revamped because nobody has cds anymore
and
um and the world is dramatically
different now yeah i think
another one virtually sort of like a
master class type feel where you could
download
classes and blah blah because everybody
really wants to know how to break into
voice over and it's not easy and
so many um companies are very willing to
take money from hopefuls and
offer any real advice i hate these
companies that say you have to
you know join our site and pay to
audition like no one in my world got
here because we paid to audition it's
such a scam and
it really irks me that people take
advantage of hopefuls in that way
so um i i'd like to revisit that again
soon yeah i think that's great because
there is
you know there's all this misinformation
that gets thrown around in
you know traditional hollywood but the
the voice over world there's it's not as
prevalent there so i'm sure people are
much more susceptible to being scammed
in some way
right um do your sons have an interest
in the entertainment world
well they both are super talented and
funny
i don't know that they want to do it for
careers but they're both
very gifted my older son's an
extraordinary musician
um you actually just wrote the theme
song for my new podcast which is the
ship it show and
oh that's so sweet yeah greg sypes and i
explore
all things love in fandom it's really
fun we let them we let the fans vote
each week on which ship we should
explore
that's on rooster teeth right yeah it's
on rooster teeth yeah and we're having a
lot of fun with that and my younger one
um and i have worked together on camera
a couple times um
and they've both done some voice over
stuff here and there so it's not like
um they have to be like mom and it's
like a passion but they're both good at
it and could if they really pursued it
that's very sweet uh do
you have a character that is the most
similar
to you in real life i'd say
probably bubbles because
she's super sweet um and wants everybody
to be happy but she could
also kick some ass when she has to yeah
yeah she can be pretty hardcore yeah
and that's like me i'm a human that will
put up with a lot and and be accepting
and hope people will change for the best
and then when i'm done with you
you'll give them the opportunity to
change themselves first and if that
doesn't work then you have to
step in a little bit bye-bye
i love it now i have a question about
what's the difference if there is any in
doing voice over for video games
which you've done versus like a tv or a
film
project the biggest difference between
animated
series and video games is how you record
them in
animation series we typically all tape
together which is really nice to play
off the other actors because a lot of
acting is listening so you're going to
respond to someone differently if
an actor goes it's time to go you might
go okay
yeah that way um video games because
there's so many queues thousands and
thousands of queues
you tape a loan so it can actually be
more vocally taxing to have to be in a
booth for four hours by yourself
often screaming death sounds um in terms
of the acting it comes from the same
place and there's no difference it's
really just in the mechanics of how they
record them
okay now let's talk about tara the human
being
what do you do when you're not working
well first of all i'm always working
that's great
wonderful and that is one of the true
treats of being in the voice over world
while we're in a pandemic
it really is um i also really really
love
being a mom um and i'm very hands on and
i
like to have dinner and play chess and
pool and hang out with my kids i'm crazy
for animals so
i love to play with animals and it
wasn't a pandemic i'd be like at every
rescue
place right now playing with animals um
i
um i love being social i love having
friends over i love to work out
um a nice balance yeah i like going on
hikes i like um
you know being involved politically is
something i started once trump was
considering running and i didn't i
didn't
really have interest in politics until
it enraged me
which in same with me yeah and it's too
bad because obviously there's so many
important things that we all are missing
and
maybe that's why this all happened so
people would wake up and stand up and
take notice
especially for people that are suffering
um
because they're not you know a white
america a right american
you know citizen and so many things need
to change and have been wrong for so
long that
any way that i can help by bolstering
democratic candidates
and um things that are right like there
should not be children in cages there
yeah you you know there should not be
police brutality against black people
there should not be like
the homeless there's so many things to
fight for that sometimes it gets
overwhelming and you're like how
how can i help everyone yeah and i think
the answer is helping a little is is
helping
and so i try to do that too and it's
obviously so stressful right now so
thank god for ponies
yeah i know well that's one it's it's
wild because you
um you have dual citizenship right in
the
us and in canada so not only have you
experienced what's going on in america
by being in america you've also
experienced
it from the outside looking in as well
which is fascinating to me
um and and i'm like how have you not
run back to canada if you have the
option well actually i
i am in canada right now i'm doing it
yeah i'm doing a tv show
here and i really want to stay um
because it is much more sane here
and it was disappointing to see
true america it was disappointing to see
it today to see how close this election
is
and i think prior to trump much of
the racism anti-semitism misogyny was
sort of
hidden um and then seeing how emboldened
they
became with his rhetoric i was
pretty surprised and am daily i i can't
tell you how many stupid anti-semitic
things i get thrown at me
or um you know of course
i i i just like don't get me started
like it's really disappointing it's wild
too because i
i'm with you i'm it's it's still taken
some time for me to process
how shocked i am by a lot of it
and the unfortunate thing i think is
like the internet is a blessing and a
curse
and has really divided us in a lot of
ways when it does have the ability to
unite us um which is wild and i guess
like the the saving grace about that is
that working in these animated series
that do bolster
uh inclusion and love and friendships
and things like that
at least you can take solace in knowing
that the work you're producing
will have a positive impact in some way
and hopefully deeper than you can even
imagine for people
but yeah it is um it's a it's a wild
time
for everyone right now um
well when you aren't watching the news
as we all are constantly in between
every
waking moment of everything else we're
doing what do you
watch on tv or movies or anything like
that
i'm not really a big tv person it's
it's been during covid like at the end
of a workday that i sit down and
and start binge watching and i've caught
up a lot during covid i
i never watched stranger things so i
watched all of stranger things which i
loved
i watched the umbrella academy which was
a lot of fun
i watched nurse ratched i watched
the queen's gambit which was great oh i
haven't gotten to that yet
i i mean of course tiger king when that
first came out
and that was at the beginning of all of
this which is my mind
i i've watched so much netflix i
you know it's good it's thank goodness
we have this content to keep us going
and
um engaged i i can't imagine
how they dealt with pandemics 100 years
ago where you couldn't
go turn on your computer and talk to
someone you know even this is such a
blessing to be able to
connect in some way with humans i miss
touching people hugging people like
we don't have that so at least we can
communicate thank you god for the
internet and zoom right now even though
there's a lot of ugly parts
of the internet i have to believe that
the good outweighs the bad
and hopefully after this craziness is
over we can try to come together
as a country and in kindness and empathy
and listening to each other that would
be a real blessing
i also championed second ditto
support that 200 um
let's talk a little bit about dream
roles is there a type of character that
you haven't played yet that you would
love to play
or a a genre that you haven't worked in
yet that you'd love to work in
i have to say like animation wise all my
dreams have come true like i really
wanted to
be the little mermaid so getting to sing
with jody benson in the sequel and play
her daughter like i could have died the
next day
um and all the very strong female
superhero characters
i've got to play and grow with have been
fascinating and rewarding
um i'm doing something on camera right
now that's really fun so
that that's happening probably i'd love
to go do a broadway show
when all this is over i think that'd be
really fun
yeah you haven't done that yet no i i've
done theater in toronto and locally in
la but never on broadway and i think
that would be really fun
that makes so much sense and i think
everyone is very much looking forward to
that potentially happening
um okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back i have a bunch of
questions from instagram
they're so good everyone loves you and
has so much
uh as they're they're curious about a
lot so
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two
things a big thank you for listening to
the podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here
in this not too deep world we've built
and you'd like to leave us a review that
would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise
maybe just good or otherwise would be
appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay tara before we get into these
questions from the internet i'm gonna
ask you the two questions i ask every
single guest that's on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most like to throw
cold spaghetti at throw
cold spaghetti at yeah it's a very hard
hitting question
alive or dead who would i like to throw
cold spaghetti at
i think i'd like to throw cold spaghetti
at trump's head
that would be pretty fun that makes the
most sense 100
too violent but it's fitting and it
sends a message
okay the other question i ask every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pant [ __ ] story
or a bathroom close call but you can
only use
three words or three small phrases so
for example
mine is college jogging front lawn
wow i did not expect that question
and it can be like a bathroom situation
a peeing your pants situation it can be
from
elementary school whatever memory might
just
pop up i definitely don't have a
[ __ ] myself
one so that's good i guess that's really
good
um i mean i had a close call let's say
close call driving let's say that
close call driving okay yeah like i have
like a stomach flu that like hit me
driving i'm like oh my god what'd i do
but i made it
it was good for you yeah i have a friend
that didn't make it when i shared that
story it was gross but i made it
that's good i know that's when you
become the macgyver in your own car that
you're like what looks like a bucket
what is a container
okay let's get into these questions from
instagram like i said we have a lot of
really lovely questions here
let's see what do we want to start with
um
okay what we kind of hit on this but
what kind
of vocal warm-up does she do a lot of
people were curious about just like
what's your process when you get into
character
yeah so i i that's why i encourage
singing lessons because you record your
singing lessons and then you have
um a warm-up on hand on your phone
so if i have to sing for something i
don't always warm up but if i have to
sing for something i'll warm up using my
singing lessons
vocal warm up gotcha uh someone said no
have you ever thought about playing d
and d curious to how you would build a
uh build and voice a player
you know i've never gotten into it but
i've never played it
so i'm not ruling it out it might be
something
i would enjoy but i've never tried uh
okay yeah
if this pandemic continues it might be a
a good kind of socially distant hobby
yeah that's true that's true uh someone
to know which show
did you not expect to be so big for sure
my little pony
for sure oh yeah i mean usually i'm
working on a show i'm like oh this is
going to be big like i knew teen titans
was going to be
big um and there's been
some that surprised me like i thought
symbionic titan was going to be a big
hit
um but surprise in terms of
reach and international success
love support for sure my little pony no
idea wow well that's very cool then
it's going to be a very very warm
welcome for the new series it's so
exciting
someone's to know are there foods that
she can't eat before work because of her
voice
well i'm vegan um so that helps a lot
because dairy is terrible
for you and for your voice and i see
people struggling sometimes if they have
dairy and mucus and it's just really
gross if you are curious about it at all
watch a video called dairy is scary and
you'll know what's in it and why you
shouldn't be
consuming it um and when i was little i
was a big animal lover i never wanted to
eat meat or
or buy products there wasn't a lot of
choices but now there are
there's not really an excuse for eating
cruelty
and the meat and dairy industry are so
cruel
people don't want to be vegan because
they don't really want to look at it but
if you really look at it it's pretty
terrible
and so there's all kinds of great
cheeses that are made from nuts now that
are
so good so good and like i love oat milk
coffee drinks oh my gosh it's like
drinking cake
yeah um so i i'd say
um separate of no dairy things that
might crumble in your throat aren't
smart like a cookie
oh and then sometimes when you're
recording a show you might want to eat
on on the show like sometimes it's a
character takes a bite of an apple take
a bite of an apple
or a chip or something that's going to
make a loud crunch you know you can make
the noise
um with your voice but it's also
sometimes kind of fun to
actually chew something yeah you're
recording if it's not
you know stated that you're eating
you're mostly not eating so
i'd say just make sure that you've had
something in your belly or else you do
get a loud tummy and that's not great
either i've
had lots of takes like ruined because
your tummy is like making noises and the
mics are so sensitive they pick up tummy
noise and stuff wow i've never thought
about that possibility yeah so don't
starve yourself and don't drink cow's
milk
got it good to know i think those
regardless of whether
you are a voice over actor or not is
just good life advice
exactly uh someone to know what was your
favorite cartoon voice or character
growing up
if you had one i loved cartoons growing
up i loved the flintstones i loved
the jetsons i loved the smurfs
um those are probably my top there was a
show here called wait till your father
gets home which i really loved when i
was a kid
and there was like a rubik's cube show
what
it was called rubik or something that
sounds great yeah but probably jetsons
and flintstones were like my go-to's
love that uh someone's to know how does
she manage your time doing so many
voices
well um managing my schedule is
pretty challenging i have to say it
sounds like there's a lot on your plate
there's a lot all the time and often in
the entertainment industry there's last
minute things
and you're constantly moving stuff
around
thank god i have extremely gifted agent
my agent matanya rose at dpn who handles
my
animation then i have juliet green who
manages me across the board then i have
butler wrestling bell in toronto that
does my canadian stuff then i have my
bestie roxy that manages that helps
assist me and i have my friend adam that
says to me i have all these people like
i have a good village but in truth
not missing anything is is challenging
and i'm a pretty conscientious human so
i i like to be present for all things
i've committed to and sometimes that's
hard
it's really hard to do life things like
you often have to change a hair
appointment or a doctor's appointment
um you know there was one time i was
supposed to fly out to do a con
and i got the opportunity to work in the
new star wars movie like the day
where i flew with mark hamill like you
know
on a dubbing stage and i'm like yeah i
got to do that so i had to move stuff
around like sometimes you have to be
flexible to move stuff around yeah it
seems like um
there's a certain level of being
comfortable with uncertainty
at times being comfortable with
flexibility at times
and you know sometimes you get
frustrated but i also know like
maybe like i'd miss that level of
busy like i think i i am a human that
sort of thrives when i have a million
things to do and
when i don't and there's a slum i'm like
well i better go do something i'm
someone that likes to be busy you know i
worked with um
stan lee before he passed he was in his
90s and he came in to do some spider-man
and i'm like what is your secret and he
said do what you love and never retire
and get paid to do what you love and
that's that's true like if you're doing
what you love
that's the best gift ever yeah you're
never really working at that point
uh someone wants to know how was it
doing more adult themed cartoons like
princess clara and drawn together
well as a human who spends most of her
time doing things for children
it's super liberating and fun to get in
a studio and say
swear words so i'm not gonna lie
that was some fun times i would love to
do more drawing together i mean
i remember my mother-in-law was visiting
me once and we went i took her to a
couple recordings and first was rugrats
and then we went to drawn together and
i'm like just so you know this isn't
progress
someone's curious what are your tips for
a canadian moving to los angeles
hmm that's tricky um you know i took off
when i was 20 and i knew
two people and um it's scary
i think the tip is to stay grounded
um to try to connect with people
um that are doing well or have already
settled so you're not ending up in a bad
area or listening to
bad advice there's a lot of canadians in
los angeles and
there's sort of this network that help
each other out
and not to get discouraged with that
said
if it's not working out don't be afraid
to come home because there's so much
work
in canada it's like such a blessing um
so as long as you're working and
you know maybe it's not in the cards for
you to get some big american series but
maybe you'll work on something in canada
that's really so fulfilling and
you get to work on it for years and
years and maybe win some canadian awards
and
hang out with authentic people so it's
not the worst thing in the world if you
go and it doesn't work out
yeah or if you don't and it works out
and you still want to come back
um like there's no real rules you know
because so much of this business is
timing
you could have the most talented the
most beautiful the most gifted performer
never get a shot yeah um and then you
have someone that's
mediocre but gets lucky in this kick-ass
part so
i don't know so much of it is luck and
timing and i guess just not to give up
and
and keep going for your dreams wherever
they may fall that's beautiful
because it is a lot of persistence and i
think
los angeles will always be here that if
you need to leave you can come back
if you need to right and it's going to
probably be exactly as you left it
it doesn't seem like much change you
know coming home now there's even more
work here so yeah
um and so much of the stuff is seen in
the united states
and sometimes it's better for on-camera
work
here because like i said in la a-listers
are willing to do
television and so it leaves not a lot of
room for
other people to do episodic work whereas
here
um there's so many more opportunities
and way less
a-list celebrities sort of taking roles
away from people that might be better
suited for a part
totally and something people probably
don't think about
right um okay last question for you why
do you think
some of the most famous and well-known
boy cartoons are voiced by women
well the main answer is because boy
voices change so
you can't have like a little boy in a
season of a show that takes off and then
next season they have a completely
different voice which is of course what
happened in chowder which is one of my
favorite shows that i ever did
i think they made a mistake on that show
i think they should have got
you know 10 seasons in the can before
that kid's voice changed because he was
so cute
so consistently they pick women that
are um good at authentic boy voices
because the voices don't change also
um you know for studios
they don't have to hire a set tutor if
there's um
not a child on set um and
um also you know voice actors get paid
a scale rate for up to three different
characters so it makes sense for them to
hire someone versatile if someone can do
a little boy
and a store owner and a girl like
they're gonna pick someone that can
manipulate their voice and play a bunch
of different roles
oh that's interesting yeah has it been
have there been any
i guess most interesting parts of
playing someone like
timmy um because i imagine
but i don't know that there's a mostly
male following to that character or is
that pretty
even spread apparently appearance is one
of those shows that really also
across the board girls boys everybody
loved that show
i think more for me people were
surprised when they found out i was ben
10
that's really a boy voice centric show
or terrance on foster's home they're
like that was you
which is a huge um compliment when a
voice actor says i didn't know that was
you
oh that's cool yeah so yeah it happened
sometimes we were like ben 10's a girl
and she's a mom
that happens more than for fairly ad
parents that's true oh that's
very fun uh tara we've reached the end
of the episode but before you go
um we like to give our guests a little
parting gift for making time for us
and that is a digital fortune cookie
from us
to you that is personalized that i
believe melissa might have emailed
to you it says it is important to have
your voice heard like literally
literally your voice
like we really really like it yeah
it's what the world needs right now it
is so
so very true tara thank you for spending
time with us today
and where can people watch pony life
where
can they see everything that you're up
to and follow you if they don't already
know
pony life is discovery family and you
can watch it streaming on the discovery
family go
app um you can follow me on all my
social media platforms i'm at tara
strong and of course check out my new
podcast with greg sypes
at the shipwreck show and it's on
youtube and wherever you find your
podcasts
i love it thank you so much guys go
check out everything that she's up to
it's really good stuff
and we'll see you next time on another
episode that's not too deep goodbye
thanks for having me too deep too deep
too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music